your primary plan can your campaign the
UPI I mean that is an idea whose time
has come and it was almost like you know
you were a prophet in light of what was
soon to arrive and in terms of it an
economic Cataclysm the podcast that
started it all
Andrew yang and Sam Harris so if you are
listening this right now whether you
know it or not it is because of sam
harris in fact if you have any opinion
about andrew yang do you love him you
hate anything he's gonna be President
United States you think he's a genius
thing he's an idiot does not matter that
opinion is because of sam Harris so Sam
Harris is a neuroscientist thought
leader has his own podcast called making
sense and Andrea enjoined this podcast
in July of 2018 right as he started his
presidential run because of that podcast
we started building our grassroots
fundraising operation we built the
infrastructure for the yangyang we
started growing getting more popular and
eventually because of Sam we got on Joe
Rogan's podcast and took off on a
national scale and launched the entire
presidential campaign in this massive
national movement and it is so clear in
round two of this conversation why that
happened you've Sencha ly got these two
titans of long-form conversation coming
together and talking about both what
happened since the last conversation but
now talking about how Co vyd has
accelerated the arrival of our future
and how it affects all of us so this
conversation is remarkable it's longer
than our usual but it's worth every
freaking second enjoy it guys yang
speaks with Sam Harris
[Music]
Sam how are you oh my gosh
general yang launched my entire
presidential run really that's barely an
exaggeration that's that there's this
period with everyone who is supporting
our campaign was because they heard me
on your podcast
yeah well it's really it was it was
amazing to witness and I was very happy
to play a part in it obviously the the
major assist was to get you on Rogen's
podcast after you did mine which just
completely blew you up because he has
this an audience so large that the
mainstream media has yet to even
understand what's happening in
podcasting it was fantastic to watch
your ascendancy and you know I can only
imagine it's the beginning of the Andrew
yang show on various fronts so I I'm
happy to see the The Adventures who's
great to be a part of it
well you've been a huge part of it Sam
and I have to tell you that ice I
remember our conversation and then I
remember watching your your conversation
with Joe on AI after you and I spoke
right and then I realized oh my gosh Sam
was waiting for someone like me where
you'd been talking about try to prepare
society for AI for years and you were
like how the heck is this gonna happen
and I only figured out after the fact
that you'd essentially paved the road
for me before I even come along I think
in any political cycle you would be a
breath of fresh air but in the current
environment I mean now even more so but
you know back when you first appeared
what was so amazing and depressing was
you know the juxtaposition between what
should be possible in a u.s. president
and what is actual in the case of Trump
before you know anyone ever heard of you
we all knew that there are people in the
world who understand science and who
have read widely and who are deeply
curious about the way that
world works and who are normal human
beings will fall in love with some
person and at some point in their lives
you know who feel real compassion for
the suffering of other people and people
who are clearly moved by ethical
arguments and the progress of ideas and
you are clearly one of these people
you're someone for whom it's obvious
that the last thousand years of human
progress has meant something and what we
have in place of a person like that in
the Oval Office we have a barbarian with
a smartphone who appears to love nothing
but fame and money and golf and an
interesting thought has never escaped
his lips yeah I mean the juxtaposition
is so grotesque the level of hope that
was you know hurled on your shoulders
was kind of abnormal because of you know
the context in which you're appearing
but it really it's um the fact that
you're not in any sense a normal
politician is wonderful and and I hope
we draw more and more lessons from how
far you got in the last campaign and and
I hope you stay in the center of our
conversation about how to dig out of
covert land because obviously your
primary plank and your campaign the UPI
I mean that is an idea whose time has
come and it was almost like you know you
were a prophet in light of what was soon
to arrive and in terms of an economic
Cataclysm so yeah I'm looking forward to
talking through all of this with you
it's quite a moment we're living through
yeah I thought we're gonna automate jobs
and send everyone home and it turns out
that we're all home for a different
reason
hmm right now you know I was joking with
some but I was serious I got I do think
that I had the only stump speech that
referenced the Spanish flu of 1918 furby
I was saying that that was the last time
American life expectancy declined for
three years in a row right which we just
had happen in the the last three years
but
this time I have to say Sam's like the
things I was concerned about I have all
been compressed into a very short
timeframe know instead of closing 50
percent of America's malls we've closed
virtually all of them and now I know
some of them are reopening but a lot of
those jobs are gonna be gone for good
yeah so I mean maybe we can talk about
what you think the kovat pandemic has
exposed in our society and obviously
it's accelerated the arrival of the
future what are you expecting to be true
once we emerge from this at whatever
point of it what equity in terms of the
effects on the economy and how effective
or not our pumping trillions of dollars
into the system will be and how the
post-mortem on that might reveal
incredible levels of corruption
what do you expecting to be true in six
months or a year I think these are
catastrophic times for tens of millions
of Americans and it's frustrating that
for whatever reason the gravity of the
situation is not as clear to some people
as it is to me or others who know how
tenuous a hold many Americans already
had on their month-to-month
paycheck-to-paycheck ability to make
ends meet and watching our government
try to send money to people even is
incredibly frustrating because we're
missing so many people yeah the
mechanisms were using you know like
hearing these stories of people calling
their state unemployment office day
after day and just never getting through
and because we're asking systems to do
things that they're not designed to do
like the state unemployment office is
not designed all of a sudden take
millions of inquiries and the thing that
occurs to me as I think would occur to a
lot of people listening to this why do
people have to call a phone it connect
to a person in order to access these
benefits that have been authorized
Andrew let's drill down on that for a
second because this is so bizarre and
potentially it's such a missed
opportunity so your idea which
originate with you but which you have
brought into such prominence of
universal basic income is that this is
something that the government can do
well right we should be able to just
send checks to everybody but in the
current environment we're recognizing
that even that isn't good enough we need
a digital infrastructure that can
directly give money to people and
correct me if I'm wrong currently you
can't even apply for this money unless
you have a previous tax return which is
gonna leave out millions of people who
most need money so maybe you can discuss
how far we're falling short of what
should be possible here in terms of just
getting money to people as quickly as we
can
so I just want to relate my experience
with my organization just a number of
weeks ago we were trying to get money
into people's hands and we called
JP Morgan Chase we called Citigroup and
said hey can we get money to people in
the Bronx who have accounts with you and
need it and they couldn't help us we
even asked them can we buy bank cards
from you that we will somehow physically
get into people's hands they couldn't
help us with that we wound up working
with a local organization that had
people's financial info neighborhood
trust and we sent a million dollars to a
thousand families in the Bronx
through that organization and my direct
experience with this is the same
experience we're having society-wide
where the government saying okay let's
send everyone money
let's send everyone $1,200 and then they
look around and say well how do we know
where people are how do we know what
account to send the money to or address
if it's a check and the best information
they have is through tax returns that's
the majority of the mechanism they're
using and that misses tons of people and
misses it turns out millions of people
who didn't file taxes because they made
below a certain amount or they're
working in frankly some kind of informal
environment where maybe they're cleaning
people's houses and they're just getting
paid cash and so you know they didn't
file taxes either because they didn't
make enough or because frankly they were
just like well like I'm just gonna
operate and pay my bills in cash so
because we're using people's tax returns
if you didn't have that connection to
the government and a bank account on
record for them to return your your tax
refund too then you're not getting money
and that's unfortunately that's tens of
millions of the most needy Americans
because if you can imagine the folks
that aren't filing taxes many of them
are quite poor yeah the thing about ubi
which strikes me is so much better than
many remedies that seem very much like
it is that
no question of means-testing it because
people worry will go does it really make
sense to be sending Jeff Bezos a
thousand dollar check that seems like a
waste of money but obviously if our tax
structure were rational Jeff would be
paying an enormous amount to me more
than anyone back into the system and
taxes so it wouldn't matter if he was
also on the dole getting ubi right so it
seems like we should just take all the
friction out of this and get money to
everyone in the right increments
whatever that is yeah we should be
flooding the zone with money honestly
and the the incredibly frustrating thing
is that if you really want in to account
for the Jeff's of the world you could
just take out of their tax returns later
you know it's like like they can just
get pay it back in twenty twenty or
twenty twenty-one and their tax returns
next year and I've talked to people who
did not qualify for stimulus checks
because their income was too high in
2018 and they're in desperate straits
now and I was like their income has gone
to zero maybe they had a small business
and so they're looking up saying like
why am I not getting this twelve hundred
dollars we should be giving them the
twelve hundred dollars and if it turns
out they didn't need it we can always
just clawed back in taxes later though
to me that shouldn't even be that
necessary but if you were going to worry
about the Jeff's of the world you could
always just get it back after the crisis
has abated right like the the theory
being that right now we're in crisis
mode right so my concern now is that
this is going to increase wealth
inequality in ways that will be
politically intolerable and you know how
we navigate that moment I think is
everything hinges on that I mean I worry
about the loss of social cohesion I
worry about a level of political
partisanship that really seems to be
indicative of a failing country and I
feel like we've been on the cusp of that
really every day under Trump with
respect to the level of partisan
rhetoric and the degree to which the two
sides can't get on
same page for the purposes of ordinary
political compromise and you obviously
at this point know much more about that
than I do but I just worry that in the
aftermath of whatever is going to happen
here economically the people who will
whether this you know much better than
anyone else are the people who are
already very well off and whether a
middle class exists in a year is really
an open question and so um I just wonder
what your thoughts are about that and
what did you learn through the
experience of campaigning all that time
and go into more American cities than I
will ever go to in the rest of my life
you should join me next time say I'm
joined you gotta be City we could be
tied the Terps of dubber of tout halls
it had to be an amazing experience so
what's your view of of our ongoing
economic emergency between now and next
year you hit the nail on the head where
we are going to eviscerate what's left
of the American middle class there was
an executive in
Silicon Valley vallah Afshar who said
2020 will vastly accelerate the adoption
of and then he listed ten things and you
think about them you're like oh yeah all
of that's happening ecommerce drone
delivery digital contactless payments
videoconferencing autonomous vehicles
wearable health monitors 3d
manufacturing voice mobile applications
online learning and smart robotics those
things were already on the table and now
we've just revved them up into overdrive
because we need to do some of these
things for public health reasons and if
you look at autonomous cars and trucks
wouldn't you rather get picked up in a
vehicle that has been sanitized and a
human has not satin unfortunately like
all of the arguments as I go you need a
person for that it's like now that the
person is a net negative in terms of
someone's confidence level some in terms
of not just the way we feel about it but
the actual transmission rate of the
coronavirus and so you're seeing
companies that were on the fence about
throwing people overboard and automating
processes now make in making a very very
clear investment in these technologies
and you can see it in what the stock
market is saying where when people are
announcing record layoffs their prices
they go up though the stock values go up
because investors know that if you can
shrink your workforce then the returns
on capital will be higher so this is
going to be disastrous for tens of
millions of American workers over time
and the government is the only entity
that can meaningfully try to resuscitate
the middle class and the opportunities
available to most Americans in the days
to come and I know many people listening
to this are not going to love the
message that the government is going to
be the center of the universe for these
decisions but unfortunately that's what
we're faced with yeah well that's always
the first sticking point wait when you
talk to someone who
fantastically wealthy person who recoils
at the idea of paying more in taxes who
doesn't like the concept of
redistribution not because they are
callously inconsiderate of the suffering
of other people not because they don't
care about wealth inequality it really
that the first thing you encounter is
that everyone has a fundamental
skepticism and granted some of this is
well-earned that the government can do
anything right that it just seems like a
waste of money to give the government
more money to try to solve problems and
there's this you know the strain of
libertarianism that suggests that it
should by default more or less always
fall to the private sector to solve
these problems but a few things I think
should be obvious here one is that there
are many problems for which the private
sector can't produce a ready solution
either because the incentives just
aren't there or you just have a massive
coordination problem and you just can't
respond flexibly all at once
and I think you know responding to a
global pandemic is certainly an obvious
commercial for a problem that needs to
be solved even beyond government we need
a global response to this problem the
lack of you know our internal leadership
is galling and terrifying but you know
our complete abdication of any role in
the wider world
in coordinating a response to kovat is
also just embarrassing but so the idea
that we should be starving the
government in the context where at any
moment problems of this sort can appear
and we're dealing with you know a public
health emergency and an economic
emergency simultaneously and you know we
have these piecemeal efforts of you know
various well-intentioned billionaires
you know riding in on their white horses
to solve some very local problem in
delivering PPE or something you know and
then probably the most heroic case you
have Bill Gates really doing great work
inspiring you know vaccine research and
or Jack Dorsey committing a billion yeah
yeah I mean so that's great but I mean
clearly that is not a surrogate
for the wise use of government resources
and even if you think the government is
just incompetent and can't spend your
money well the answer to that problem is
to create a better government yeah it's
it's actually get it operating at a
higher level not to say it's like oh
well because like you said there really
is no other answer to some of these
massive problems yeah yeah so it's uh
it's an incredible time it's the
impossible task man I remember when I
was telling people I was going to run
there's a Silicon Valley CEO who said to
me he was like what are you doing like
you're going into the most useless if
possible because he liked me it like you
know thought thought I was effective and
he was like why are you running headlong
into the the universe of in efficacy and
then I said to him I said look like it
are things working well in government no
in many many respects but like do we
need to get it working at a higher level
to avoid calamity I say yes and I said
this obviously before the coronavirus
crisis came you know it's funny Sam my
wife and I and this is a little while
ago but there was like an interview you
sat down for and you were you were
describing me and you said something
about it's like this andrew yang fellow
he seems like a normal enough guy except
that he's crazy enough to ruin his life
running for president no no no yeah so
what are your thoughts on that front I
mean what was your what's the net of
your experience running and do you think
you will run again or find or seek some
other role in government what's the plan
there
well my motivations are the same as
they've ever been and the problems have
gotten bigger unfortunately like I
thought well it's unacceptable that
we're letting this freight train just
bear down on us and just ignore it and
and in my mind the freight train was the
progressive dehumanization of our
economy and I saw in the numbers that we
already blasted away millions of
manufacturing jobs and there was no real
feedback mechanism unless you count
Trump and his victory because most of
those manufacturing jobs were in
Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Missouri like the swing states that
Trump all won and now the problems are
bigger than ever and you know my
motivation is as high as it's ever been
so I'm just still trying to solve
problems every day and my capacity to
solve problems is higher now than it was
when I started my presidential run so so
there's there's no change on that front
I mean I certainly learned a lot about
becoming president but for president
where I I have a sense as to what I'd
missed when I sat down with you a couple
years ago like I didn't realize that the
process was going to entail certain
things but as long as the problems are
there and and I'm able to contribute I'm
gonna do it and if that includes running
for office again and that's what I'm
gonna do is there anything you would do
differently in hindsight no it's really
fascinating I mean I could definitely
talk about this for a while I mean one
change I would make is that I did not
realize that there were a couple hundred
Beltway journalists in DC that had
significant influence over the press
narrative and I did not sit down with
most of them and most of them treated me
like a marginal anomaly slash novelty
/ignore man will go away
[Laughter]
and I'm not sure if my sitting down with
them would have changed that not all of
them are as thoughtful as someone like
you where you just evaluate someone
based upon your own judgement of them
like that's one thing I figured out too
is that there are so many people that
represent these institutions that didn't
really think for themselves they just
like operated on whatever the
institutional incentives or motivations
were so I don't know if my sitting down
with these couple hundred people would
have moved the needle but I would have
done that the there is that there were
so many learnings in Iowa and in New
Hampshire where we got my favorables up
and this is actually true nationwide
where my favorability ratings were as
higher higher than virtually any other
candidate in terms of do people like me
trust me think
reasonable thing I'm well intended and
we just couldn't get them over the
threshold of this person should be
president like right now right we got a
lot of people to a point where they were
like really like yang like really hope
he becomes a cabinet member or something
along those lines but we couldn't quite
get people over a threshold of put him
in the White House this year and if I
run again that's one of the things I'm
spending my time doing is frankly
normalizing myself more where it just
felt like a little bit too much change
for some people right right yeah I can
imagine it was also the calculation of
you know electability it's like a you
know I want this guy to be president but
I would imagine that the rest of the
country might not or he will he's not
gonna be able to sell himself in this
election cycle and so for anyone who's
privileged in getting rid of Trump above
all else that's has to be a factor I
mean that's how we wound up with Biden
right is Biden anyone's first choice I'm
not sure but the electability
and not Trump calculus has gotten us
here
[Music]
okay so I launched a podcast and then
someone sends me an electric scooter and
then I ride it around on it and it is
glorious holy crap ooh now he's like the
Tesla of electric scooters and I don't
say that lightly
it's called the unagi which is a little
bit of a weird name I think it means eel
in Japanese don't iet Nagi rolls but
this unagi scooter freakin jams I gotta
say it makes just buzzing around so much
fun I've ridden scooters obviously
unlike those bird in lime and like uber
scooters and this is a step up from that
nothing against those scooters but this
thing is just better and cooler and so
much fun so if you want to see what I'm
talking about you can check them out and
get yours at unagi scooters calm that's
un AGI scooters calm and if you use the
discount code yang you get $150 off the
unagi 500 and holy crap this thing will
change your life because it's just so
much freaking fun like you just feel
like you're in the future like an
episode of Westworld like just cruising
around but the good you know like the
good episodes right you know what I mean
it's also environmentally friendly it's
electric you know you just go in
someplace you're not using much juice
and it's just fun as hell they send you
this scooter in a box it takes 60
seconds to put it together and then it's
one snap put it away long charge goes
like 15 miles
I was zooming around the neighborhood
it's fantastic my sister videotaped me
Andrew Evelyn's videotape you you look
pretty badass too when you're riding
that thing you know well people are
trying to figure out what the hell it is
at first because you know they're like
is that a normal scooter and then they
realize it's not if you're in the market
for the scooter this thing hauls ass and
is awesome you nagi scooters calm you
and AGI scooters calm use the code yang
get $150 off for the you Nagi 500 look
like a badass feel like a badass like a
magic carpet it's awesome
I don't know if you want to plunge into
a discussion of the remaining months of
the 2020 election now or if you have a
well you know it's I mean I I'm on the
same page you are Sam where I think that
trumps a total disaster and defeating
him is job one that's why I ran and now
I'm going to help Joe defeat him because
Joe is going to be the Democratic
nominee and to me any day Trump's in
office is bad for civilization you have
had for Humanity yeah well so let's jump
into that do you and you know I'm not
sure if your tongue is going to be tied
on any of these topics but that's all
I'm just gonna just push and until I hit
a wall yeah obviously he's confined
himself to picking a a woman for VP
which he did not mention to me when I
talked to him about this very topic
right that's funny so do you have a
strong opinion about who you think he
should choose to make his chances as
favorable as possible no I I now
obviously we spent some time with Amy
Klobuchar and Kamala Harris I've met
Stacey Abrams but I don't know her well
I don't know whitmer the governor of
Michigan I don't know a couple of the
other people that we all know are in the
consideration set I like both Kamala and
Amy they're good warm human beings
behind the scenes oh and Elizabeth
Warren I shouldn't leave her out said I
know that she's also Elizabeth has
always been very generous to me as well
where I don't know if your member the
debate exchange when she was like when
you know we were arguing over automation
and I asked her to read my book and she
actually read my book we talked about it
like the next debate where she you know
commended me on it so I like the
candidates that I know Elizabeth come on
Amy
in particular I don't have any insight
as to where Joe is gonna go with that
choice
have a sense of what would be the best
choice purely from the pragmatic point
of view just getting elected you know
I'd have to look at the numbers because
I know Jo's - you must have numbers on
this where they're they're running it
hmm and I I don't have that data so I
wouldn't want to you know play pundit it
is funny say it's like like you know
obviously if anyone had run that like
Haitian Andrew yang run for president
before the fact the answer always would
have been no and so like obviously I
wasn't a very data-driven decision but
but it like when we were running did we
try and get data for any opportunity
that we had in front of us whether it
was like how we were spending our money
or who were targeting or what to name
the freedom dividend or whatever the
choices were it's like when we could get
information we'd get information there
was a point thanks to you and other
supporters where we actually could run
private polls which we would do and they
were very helpful and insightful like we
kept figuring out you know one of the
things I was proudest of Sam as we got
the approval for universal basic income
up from something like 25 percent to 66
percent in the state of Iowa and we knew
that because we were asking people about
it and so yeah it's like it is funny
it's like certain decisions you make
based upon instinct and gut and what you
think is right and then certain thing is
you try and put a finger in the wind and
get some numbers for right so now how
worried are you about the Biden campaign
at this appointment so that the two
major things that I see pulling the wind
out of his sails are obviously the the
sense that he's too old to be doing this
and here we have a I mean there are two
forms of asymmetric warfare here and the
first is I guess neurological I'm saying
every one of his gaffes seems to suggest
senescence on some level every one of
trumps gaffes seems to just suggest more
Trump and you know I have no doubt that
Biden is showing the signs of age I mean
you just have to look at video of him
speaking 20 years ago to see that
I also know I don't really care given
the current circumstance and you know
Trump is what do you want to think of
him in in neurological terms or
psychological ones and he's he's a
deranged person and he's also a terrible
speaker I mean he's he's also word salad
that you get out of him much of the time
but strangely it doesn't suggest
anything like a normal infirmity you
know even to his detractors right I mean
Trump has this preternatural energy you
know of a 300 pound child and on some
level there's an unfortunate comparison
between him and Biden with respect to
age and the inability to get to the end
of a paragraph with something like 100%
confidence they both show it but it just
shows up very differently and it has
different political consequences so
there's that concern about Biden is he
just too old to be in a debate with
Trump or to campaign successfully and
then there's the the me to scandal or
incipient scandal will you the Tara Reid
allegations and again he's up against
somebody who can match him you know 10
20 X for every me to scandal but it
doesn't matter in trumps world everyone
has priced that in you know I it
wouldn't even matter if we had video of
Trump mauling some young woman at a
beauty pageant right I mean it's just
he's functioning in a different
political universe so I'm just wondering
how you think those two issues that are
dragging on Biden are likely to play out
how concerned are you I want to say
three things about this am and I've seen
Joe Rogan's commentary on on Joe I had a
30-minute sit-down conversation with Joe
Biden last week because I was on his
podcast should air soon and he is
fine loosen strong like in that setting
and having been on the debate stage with
him a number of times then seen him
debate like that stuff's not easy no
like if you can just stand up there and
just like debate on national TV or do a
town hall for like you know our two
hours he still is very very strong in
many respects and I think that the
concern around his aging is overblown
from my exposure to him as a human being
like I've been around him and and like
he's fine right you know it's like you
and you actually could not do some of
the things he's done if you really were
struggling you know in the serious
serious way I mean of course you know
he's getting older leading in the sense
I mean that's just empirical fact but
but that stuff in my experience with him
directly is not as much of a concern and
it's been overblown for a number of
reasons part of its I think in the
internet say if you wanted to parse
something you could make anyone I think
yeah very gaffe prone yeah and you know
obviously joke you know I mean he's you
know it's like he's had some turns of
phrase that you look at you know and and
see that that you know they weren't
ideal and that the Tara Reid front you
know though the way I think about the
Sam's like like when we've seen other
people in this circumstance like a
pattern has emerged where if you look at
any of like the serial predators you
know it's like it's it's never one it's
like that there's just like this whole
freakin drumbeat mm-hmm and and in my
mind like if you were to say hey has Joe
you know like sort of intruded on
someone's personal space in a way that
we're like you know rustled or touch the
shoulder that sort of thing
it's like sure you know but to me that
one of the reasons why the media is
treating the Tara Reid allegations the
way they are is that there's like this
one isolated event that seems very very
out of character and that if he was the
sort of person that could do what he's
accused of doing in my opinion the odds
of there being other episodes that are
similar to that sometime in the
intervening 27 years would be like 99%
plus because in every other instance
it'd be like if Harvey
Weinstein did it to like one aspiring
actress and then like never again that's
not the way someone in that position of
authority who's a true predator would
operate like you would see it would
happen again
you know like months later months later
like you know there there'd be this
whole freaking cascade that we've seen
with other folks and which we've seen
with Trump you know I was he know and
when you talked about this video of him
like you know fondling someone at a
pageant I thought to myself it's like
does that exist we wouldn't be surprised
if it did right so to me those two
concerns are not really the main areas
of this election where it's gonna be
contested and that leads me to the third
thing the third thing is that this
really is going to become like it or not
I believe like a referendum on Trump hmm
and whether 50% or more of us say this
is not the direction we want the country
to be heading in we need a change and
the funny thing is Joe defeated me among
other people and Joe won states that he
didn't set foot in like there's like
this familiarity and comfort people have
with Joe where this election I believe
is going to be like an up or down vote
on Trump and I think that people are
going to put thumbs down because we're
trapped in our homes this this pandemic
has been mishandled at like the highest
levels you still have chaos in the PPE
procurement markets with the federal
government out bidding States and just
swooping in and grabbing gear for a
national stockpile and like rich states
are out bidding poor states even as the
biggest public health problems are in
poor parts of the southeast in like
Louisiana and Mississippi so I think
that Joe like you shouldn't evaluate it
as like oh you know like in the the way
where Joe's campaign is limited right
now because of the crisis like he's you
know there's no massive rally like I
expected at this point in time where I'd
be out there campaigning for Joe
cuz we'd all be out there having rallies
and and the fact that we're not is
categorically not a good thing because
it deprives Joe's campaign of the
opportunity to make a case in like
conventional ways and and have these
great backdrops and have press and
surrogates and me and dozen other people
out there pounding the pavement making
the case for him so all that is not good
but I still believe that there's a great
chance that Joe wins and Trump loses
because so many people are fed up with
this White House
well how much should we blame the other
Republicans and I guess I'm it's an
interesting question to put to you
because it's pretty obvious that the way
you campaigned and and your political
intuitions here to be as nonpartisan as
possible and then just to focus on
problems and your recognition that there
has to be a bipartisan solution to these
problems is fairly overt but when you
look at the way in which the Republican
Party has become a personality cult
around Trump people with real political
reputations you know people who used to
be serious people even if you you know
whether or not you agreed with their
policies the way in which they have
enabled this incompetent crime family
the Trump's and propped them up in the
face of a deluge of scandal really but
the deluge has been so incessant it's
impossible to focus on any part of it
long enough to blow it up into a proper
scandal it's just this has not seemed
like normal American politics may
everyone expects some degree of venality
and complicity and cowardice in politics
but this is just it just seems like
we're in another universe maybe we are
in some kind of Banana Republic
territory with how our politics has
turned and it is the story of Republican
complicity people like Mitch McConnell
and so I guess even beyond the election
I think if Trump loses in the fall I
think many people will feel like there
should be some reckoning right I mean
where I feel like we're going to need a
true
and Reconciliation Commission to process
the toxicity of the last four years and
that's in the in the best case of Biden
winning and all of us being able to to
hit reset in 2021 there's no truth of
reconciliation good tribunal coming
right politically how should how should
we walk that line in the next six months
with respect to casting blame on Trump's
enablers and just in the case of Biden
winning I guess I'm tempted to say all
right we're given a mulligan to
everybody because there's so many
problems we have to solve so you know
you remember those four years where you
you utterly destroyed the reputation of
the United States on the world stage and
flirted with the complete unraveling of
our institutions well we're just gonna
give you no harm no foul on that and
let's reset but I feel like the rancor
may not end I think that it just may not
be open to us because we will finally
confront what a horror show this has
been one thing I disagree with you on
Sam is this thing has been going on for
decades yeah well I wouldn't actually
deny that yeah I wouldn't you know yeah
I don't think you would and I think that
a lot of this is still the aftermath of
the financial crisis in 2008 when the
market crashes people lose their homes
communities are devastated and then we
turn to Wall Street for guidance as to
how to conduct the bailout we print four
trillion dollars to recapitalize the
banks no one goes to jail rich people
stay the heads of companies you know
like and then from that there's still
been this massive like lack of
accountability where people looked up
and said how the heck do these people
trash the economy and and no one's
punished
and then the the opiate epidemic with
Purdue Pharma killing tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of Americans like
our sons daughters neighbors kids like I
can't tell you how many times I was on
the trail and people had children died
of drug overdoses it happened all the
time not all the time like literally
I've met dozens hundreds of Americans
who would say to me either during an
event or right after the event that was
my son that was my brother everywhere
mean it was something like like nine
Americans dying an hour and so when you
go out to towns like that's their son
daughter wife and does anyone go to jail
for Purdue Pharma no dislike the
saccular family get buildings at Harvard
named after them and yes like their
museum wings named after them site sure
Sackler wing great and it's literal
blood money and and then years after the
fact
now some lawsuits are being brought and
Purdue Pharma is being held someone
accountable but the Sackler family last
I checked was still something like the
25th richest family in the country or
something along those lines and then you
have Trump and in my opinion Trump
becomes president because of the lack of
accountability where people are looking
up saying like this is not working for
me at all
these institutions are just sort of
pretending to look out for me they don't
care and then Trump comes and is they're
just saying the system is rigged drain
the swamp like these people are all full
of [ __ ] and there are millions of
Americans that were like yeah that's
right like you know and and then there
are these institutions that are like
mock horrified but meanwhile they're
sticking him on the air 24/7 they're
just ginning up the ratings or selling
the ads and then he becomes our
president and he is accelerating the
corruption and I agree with you that
it's like at a more blatant and brazen
level now where he is just trying to
bully anyone who throws an obstacle in
the way of him profiteering and his
family you know like doing multi-million
multi-billion dollar favors for friendly
supporters and companies that they have
deals with so I agree it's like a whole
nother level but this has been building
up for decades and people
so angry and despondent and distraught
and the question is how do we actually
transform this so I ran for president
because I thought we needed something
really big dramatic and I thought that
the fact that I wasn't a politician was
not a bad thing you know a lot of
Americans are like yeah sure at this
point because our politics really have
been taken captive and I can go into
detail as to the mechanics of how our
politics have been taken captive so
assuming Joe Biden becomes our president
then how does the cleanup look and the
best-case scenario which I think is on
the table is that we invest trillions of
dollars generational levels of resources
in a new Marshall Plan to rebuild the
United States of America and that we end
up rewriting the rules the economy
fundamentally and I think that's going
to be on the table because the economy
will be so broken
they'll be so much suffering so much
joblessness so much despair and that the
fundamental reality that I learned
running for president is that the
feedback mechanism between our elected
leaders and the people of this country
has been broken that essentially there
is no feedback mechanism that you're
supposed to have the ability to
obviously like elect certain people and
then the media is supposed to be holding
people accountable this stuff is not
really working the way that you would
hope it was and so now there's this
almost collective like thrashing about
for some other way to fix these things
because the feedback mechanism is broken
and the recognition among our elected
leaders and our two dominant political
parties that the feedback and mechanism
is broken is largely absent is that they
still think that the feedback mechanism
is working because they interact with
you know a relatively narrow group of
individuals who still show up to the
cocktail parties to home write the
checks still you know like do the things
that they've been doing so that so this
is like the backdrop for it
and I am optimistic that there is going
to be this once in a century opportunity
come 2021 to make big changes because no
rational person will look around and say
things are all right that we don't need
to do something big right now today huge
tech companies in America that are
paying next to nothing in taxes are
sucking up our data every single day
they are taking your web history your
email metadata your video searches and
they create a detailed profile on you
and then they cut it up into little
pieces and then sell it resell it and
we're none the wiser we don't get a dime
they're not just selling their products
anymore they're selling us they're
selling our data we have become this
product in this matrix like his system
where they're just taking our info and
making money off of it so what can we do
about it well we're working on a few
things to help but one thing you can do
is you can use Express VPN every time
you go online now what the heck is
expressvpn VPN stands for virtual
private network and if you think about
all the websites you visit every single
day using your public IP address they
can match up your activity to your IP
address and that's how they know what
you're doing so if you want to be more
anonymous online and make it so that
you're more protected and they don't
know everything you're doing then you
can sign up on expressvpn it's pretty
easy to use I downloaded this it took me
30 seconds it was the easiest thing in
the world my internet runs just as fast
Salif an I've always been a fan of VPNs
our entire staff was very big on them
during the campaign because of data
privacy concerns so if this sounds like
something you'd be into visit expressvpn
dot-com slash yang to get three months
for free on a one-year package that's
exp our e SS VPN dot-com slash yang
that's expressvpn dot-com slash yang
you'll be a little bit safe for a little
bit more
to cure a little bit more Anonymous and
the tech companies will be left a little
bit poorer as a result not that I'm out
to impoverish tech companies but you
know what I mean well how do we not lose
that opportunity let's assume I'll
having four more years of Trump is one
way to lose it obviously so that that
has to be the first hurdle we clear but
you know assuming we clear that you know
you just pointed to decades of a
bipartisan failure to not deal
successfully with the problem of you
know I would say bad incentives
ultimately and moral hazard right so the
fact that there was a bipartisan failure
not to hold anyone accountable after
2008 and the financial collapse I mean
that's that's obvious and clearly that
did pave the way for Trump I guess with
Trump that what seems impossible to have
foreseen and strikes me as highly and
not normal and and corrosive is it
really is the consequences of the
dishonesty and the you know the
devaluation of any kind of norms around
respect for institutions and expertise
and everything we've built as a
civilized - cosmopolitan society so for
instance we're in the middle of a public
health and an economic catastrophe and
you have a former president or a
Republican President George Bush putting
out a three-minute piece of video you
know trying to lift everyone's spirits
and get beyond partisanship and and
absolutely expected of him and done more
or less impeccably and then you have
Trump tweeting you know derogatory about
it saying you know where were you when I
was the victim of the greatest hoax ever
we just see his personality disorder
advertised yet again properly for the
tenth time that day and this is
something that the Republican Party now
has enabled him there were so many
turning points it was just you know they
were they were supporting Trump when he
was dancing on the grave of John
kein you know one of their superstars so
it's just the fact that we got there
seems so bizarre and I feel like there
has to be some kind of reset but I mean
to come back to your the more important
point how do we not miss this
opportunity to have a digital Marshall
Plan and because it's just that forget
about everything we're about to suffer
or we're suffering now and will continue
to suffer as a result of the pandemic
you know both you know health-wise and
financially we have these massive
problems that we don't even have the
bandwidth the grapple with them and just
like just solving the cybersecurity
problem for the next decade that was a
massive problem that we had to figure
out some way to deal with and as far as
I know we're just sleepwalking toward a
precipice there you know our current
situation imagine what life would be
like if we've lost the internet right
now I mean the internet is the only
thing keeping us together right imagine
if one of our adversaries just brought
whole sections of our digital lives to a
standstill with a cyber attack now it's
just we have to figure out some way to
to ensure that that sort of thing is a
vanishingly low probability and and we
know it isn't oh yeah no it's
significant I mean the vulnerabilities
are significant so assuming we have a
Biden administration how do we not get
back to the old normal which you know as
you point out is precisely the a system
of bad incentives and politics as usual
that got us Trump the the challenge is
getting enough unity in Congress to pass
some major major
initiatives and spending bills that put
us on our track to meaningfully recover
and a lot of it is going to be around
changing our measurements where right
now you have us still trumpeting GDP and
stock market prices that have
essentially zero relationship with how
most Americans are doing so first if you
redefine our measures of success to
revolve around our health mental health
how our kids are doing environmental
sustainability freedom from substance
abuse labor force participation rate
affordability likeability of to afford
the basics then you'd have a chance now
is that in the cards and that this is
really the big question you're posing
Sam is that do the Republicans become
reasonable company builders and partners
post Trump you know and like right now
are they just looking up and shrugging
off unacceptable venal behavior it's a
yes like do they then have to become
part of the solution starting 2021
ideally yes and I'm open to the fact
that they will have a very strong
interest in that because they're going
to go back to their communities and the
suffering is gonna be there to you know
it's like it's it's going to be
impossible to miss like they're gonna be
people lined up outside their offices at
their homes they're gonna go back to DC
and they're gonna be like all right
like what are we gonna do and so that to
me is like the the practical path
forward that I have real hope for
because Trump
over the republican party in part in my
opinion because they're ideas that run
out of gas and like what are the
trumpian ideas like you know it's
actually sort of unclear except for
bullying and having this particularly
narrow construction of like American
self-interest and a degree of
isolationism and protectionism I think
that there is going to be a real hunger
for a set of practical proposals that
people can bring back to their districts
and constituencies and say hey look we
did this so traditionally something like
infrastructure has been bipartisan where
if you come back and say hey guess what
like we're rebuilding highways we're
gonna make sure that ninety-nine point
eight percent of the country gets
Internet like that's broadband in
high-speed like these are things that I
think cross party lines you know and
then we can start thinking bigger about
how to actually measure an economy in
ways that map to the 21st century and
one of them could be for example
something around a cybersecurity
scorecard now it's much much harder to
secure infrastructure than it is to hack
it I mean that that's the truth and so I
would not want to be the person who's
saying like oh we can like somehow make
our internet invulnerable to sabotage in
that way what you have a better chance
of doing realistically is try to rebuild
some of our alliances and partnerships
abroad so that we don't have the kind of
relationship with that many actors where
they're going to be trying to bring us
down in that in that way at least the
nation level resources you know it's
like will there be individual bad actors
and organs of course but some of like
the most destructive things take
government level resources so we would
need to try to reinvest in diplomacy in
some kind of world order which the US
has become absent from over the last
number of years and this is one thing
that you can definitely lay at Trump's
feet is that Trump has done a great job
reducing our level of trust between even
our historic allies
yeah yeah I mean and he's bolstered our
adversaries I mean he's reduced both
soft and hard power despite defense
spending it's just it seems that no one
takes us seriously on the world stage
you know friend or foe and speaking of
foes you know many people now are
worrying about what seems to be a now a
cold war or at least a building cold war
with China on several fronts and it's
unhelpful that the current pandemic you
know originated there and and the talk
about this origination is so poisonous
obviously we need to find a collaborator
in China to help solve this problem and
I think that is not incompatible with
actually blaming China for certain
practices I mean whether this is the
result of wet markets or whether it's
the result of a virus that was being
studied in a lab and it leaked out you
know people seem to be fascinated by
that difference I see a distinction
without a real difference there because
in both cases it's negligence I mean
we're not talking about a weaponized
virus that has been intentionally
released but we we clearly need better
communication and collaboration to to
stop you know obviously unsafe practices
and to get everyone on the same page
epidemiologically but we have we clearly
have a many reasons to be concerned
about hostility between the US and China
and us falling into what Graham Allison
has dubbed the facilities trap you know
where we're just sort of on a path to
war because we have two superpowers one
the legacy power who's obviously
faltering and the rising power who for
various cultural reasons believes that
its supremacy is long overdue so I'm
wondering what you think about China I
mean I don't know you obviously your
last name suggests you know something
about China but know that that's
certainly what the debate moderator is
not saying right I think I got a lot of
China questions yeah how much is China
your focus with respect to global
politics it's something I'm very very
focused on and concerned about for some
of the reasons you cite it's flowing in
both directions right now where if you
look at the level of hostility towards
China in the United States it's higher
than it's been in decades it's shot up
even in this last just number of months
weeks and months and the same is true on
the other side by the way that if you
rewound a number of years most people in
China looked up to and admire the United
States and then now in part because of
some propaganda on the part of the
Chinese government there's a lot more
anti-us sentiment so we are heading
towards a Cold War dynamic or worse I
agree with you that it's you know the
fact that this virus originated in China
is making it and the Chinese government
screwed up in a massive way by not
coming clean faster you know and
suppressing information like those are
things that I'm angry about that I think
anyone could be legitimately angry about
given the scale of the crisis but if you
want to clean up the wet markets you
know who you have to deal with China so
you know how it used to be like hey
China
like let's freaking clean up the wet
markets and they're more likely to do
that if you have an actual line of
communication you know open to them some
of the biggest problems that we face
around climate change and AI and
pandemics the pandemics of the future
require that we have at least some level
of collaboration with China so how do
you navigate this tension without
letting it blow up into something like a
cold war or even worse and that's a
massive challenge and it's right now in
large part because the Republicans have
already essentially come on the record
saying hey if anyone asks you about the
coronavirus blame China and their hope
is that by framing it as a Chinese
effort even in some cases like a
racialized effort the
it just distracts from Trump's
mishandling of the pandemic and
one of the outgrowth of that is arise in
xenophobia arise in anti-chinese
sentiment that then spills over into
asian-americans because you know the
average American when they see someone
of Asian descent they're not like oh
this person's Korean American so you
they have nothing to do with my like
anti Chinese feelings we're not wired
that way at least most of us are not and
so one of the things that we have to
take great great pains in is to
distinguish between the Chinese
government which we can have very very
serious problems with but still have
recognized that we have to deal with
them if we're going to solve for some of
the biggest problems of our time and
then the Chinese people and then Chinese
Americans and then Asian Americans these
are all for very very different groups
and you can have a serious problem with
the Chinese government without somehow
ascribing it to all Chinese people are
all Asian Asian Americans or people of
Asian descent
[Music]
all right
the Jordan Harbinger show is sponsoring
our podcasts and they're sponsoring us
because we're completely aligned they
have an episode literally talking about
the jobs of the future Jordan Harbinger
is kind of a badass and he brings on
these really fascinating people to talk
about self-improvement life improvement
yeah you're talking about an FBI hostage
negotiator teaching you how to get
people to like and trust you we all want
that Navy SEALs talking about developing
mental toughness and resilience who
doesn't want to have a little bit of
agency oh-hoo badassness in their lives
episode with neil degrasse tyson telling
us how the world works the Jordan
Harbinger show is one of Apple's top
podcasts for good reason because it's
the kind of thing that most of us just
want to find out more about and they're
so serious about you internalizing each
episode that there's like a worksheet to
make sure you do it this podcast comes
with homework can you believe it but
that means it's good in this case so
check out the Jordan Harbinger show calm
sly subscribe tell them yangsun you
actually there's no way to do that but
if you were we see that it's not like
there's any credit taking for this check
out the Jordan Harbinger show on Jordan
Harbinger calm sigh subscribe on Apple
Spotify wherever you get your podcasts
[Music]
one thing that this pandemic has
revealed is how precarious our
dependence on the global supply chain is
you know the fact that we apparently
can't produce cotton swabs at scale yes
talking to the J Ansley the governor of
Washington State and he said that that
that's their bottleneck right now is
freaking swabs and I was like you gotta
be kidding me but you know like that
it's not just Washington obviously it's
everywhere
yeah so so what do you think about you
know obviously the the reasons to
globalize so many industries were purely
economic I mean was just advantageous to
get things produce more cheaply in China
and you know India and whether you're
talking about ordinary materials or the
components of drugs or even you know
whole drugs that we rely on and yet the
wisdom of that just evaporates under
conditions like this where you
absolutely mission critical things
cannot be procured and then when you add
a layer of international hostility or at
least lack of cooperation on top of that
it just seems untenable so how would you
think about bringing back critical
manufacturing to the u.s. obviously and
we're not going to produce everything we
need ourselves but may way it just seems
like a fully distributed global economy
in the current circumstance is not
working very well and we need some
backup plan now I I would adopt three
approaches Sam number one is in many of
these instances we actually could be
making the gear we need the swabs the
gowns the masks if we pushed more of our
companies to shift their operations in
that direction and we just haven't
really done it as much as we should have
this was where Trump's terrible
leadership is costing us lives if that
if if I were president right now we
could be manufacturing more of these
things even based upon what we have
right now if you were just as go to
firms and say look how much is it gonna
cost to try and
your operations to produce these things
that we need right now instead of this
like how long will it take you how much
does it cost we will make you whole we
could be doing much more in that
direction that we are not right now like
some private firms have shifted
operations voluntarily but we could be
doing much much more number two we
should have the capacity to make some of
these things ourselves
and it's not just things like cotton
swabs and PPE but like a lot of our
drugs are being made in India or China
you know and you could look at that and
say well that's actually something that
we can't just and necessarily globalize
or outsource in that way and that we
would want to invest in some kind of
ongoing domestic production facility
even if it was just a contingency plan
if it was subsidized by the government
one of the big problems here Sam is that
we've just grown to worship the market
so much yeah that when our government
says oh that thing loses money then
everyone like turns on it so I go with a
post offices losing money [ __ ] the post
office like it's ridiculous I guess the
purpose of government the purpose of
government is to pay for the thing that
the market does it support yeah so the
fact that the market doesn't support it
is not a reason not to do it it's like
hey what you need a domestic drug
production facility in case of emergency
yes right and then you just spend the
money on it and then you hope you don't
need it and then when you do need it you
thank goodness you have a functional
government number three is if you are
going to outsource production of various
things then you need to try and maintain
really positive diplomatic relationships
with the the countries that are housing
these products and so now that's a tall
order but you know that's the reality
like if all of our drugs are being made
in India and China not all are but you
know significant proportion are then you
have to try and make sure that you have
ready access if you're in a crisis
situation which means trying to rebuild
relationships with these countries
rather than doing the opposite yeah this
is just one of those areas where
doctrinaire libertarianism which
unfortunately infects so much of the
culture of wealth especially so
like in Valley I find I mean just you
just have a lot of smart people who for
whatever reason read on R and too early
as so as to be inoculated against her
false
they think that Atlas Shrugged is the
greatest book ever written and they just
don't see how ludicrous it is to think
that absolutely everything we could
possibly want to do as a species can be
most efficiently motivated by an
unregulated market right it's just there
are drugs that most people will only
have to take once in their life
but the availability of those drugs is
the difference between life and death
right it's a bad business to get in from
a pure profit motive and yet do we want
to be able to produce those drugs you
know obviously we do so it's just well
Silicon Valley is an extreme environment
Sam but here's though like what happens
is there are people that fought fought
fought in a very very competitive market
driven environment and then if they win
and they're now rich beyond imagination
then it's very hard for them to turn
around and then say well it turns out
like this system that I have fought my
way through it turns out is missing like
the these whole other sets of concerns
or problems like it's very difficult to
be able to think and feel that way if
you meant years and years like climbing
up through through a jungle essentially
and the best of the folks are folks like
Jack Dorsey who you know it was like
look I've got billions of dollars and
how can I put it to use in a way that
benefits humanity the most and like even
though I made this money like you know
the money has to have a purpose beyond
itself and I I know I mean I know you
have many friends in tech as I do and
some of them resemble both extremes
really some of them have said things
that I've been in a room for them and
like oh my gosh like I get it like a
negative way where it's like those legs
I think that that you were saying I'm
glad like no it's recording this and
then others will like express like these
incredible aspirations for you
a lot of people supported my campaign in
Silicon Valley a lot of people support
universal basic income in Silicon Valley
in part because they see what the future
of work will be and now everyone's
seeing it but also because some of them
are just excellent people excellent
human beings like they they see
pointless human suffering that can be
alleviated they want to do it and so you
know like that those are some of my
favorite people who have you know in
some ways they've been like freed of
some of like this market-based thinking
because they reached a certain point and
they said okay like what is the point of
my success and then they turn towards
higher pursuits that elevate us all yeah
and the crucial point for me ethically
is to observe in one's own life how much
of one success is due to luck really on
some well if you read the word luck
correctly it's virtually all of it all
the tools you are using to succeed
however inherent they seem to your own
person you know your intelligence your
grit your desire to try again even after
you fail right none of these are things
that you've invented right I mean you're
finding these resources in yourself
based on you know your jeans and your
upbringing and happenstance you can't
account for the idea that anyone is
truly self-made is a fantasy and then
there's that just the obvious rolls of
the dice that no one can own and which
can mean everything for the outcome of
an enterprise I mean the fact that I'm
able to work in the current environment
had more or less a hundred percent of my
prior efficiency is due to pure look
even to sharpen that up more clearly I
mean I was talking to a screenwriter
friend the other day I would actually a
married couple you know both of whom are
screenwriters you know one of whom can
have nothing produced because he he
writes ordinary television and films but
his wife is in the middle of production
on an animated show right and and so
there's absolutely no problems just by
dumb luck she's writing a cartoon
for grown-ups and everything's going
fine right so she planned it that way
Sam you saw the pandemic coming cartoons
only for me however fortunate you are
you know you could be at the end the
0.1% of the economy or right in the
middle whole fortunes depend on pure
changes in look in circumstances like
this and in really every other
circumstance and so to recognize that is
to want to cancel the most shocking
consequences of that kind of inequality
there's so many people out there who
walk walking around thinking as you say
they worked really hard I mean the
difference is rich people today for the
most part work harder than anyone else
it's not to say that their jobs are by
definition harder it's not you know
obviously you know they're not breaking
a rock that they used to be like the
leisure class who would like to yeah
play polo this is not Downton Abbey in
Silicon Valley or I mean that people are
working their asses off and they feel
they they own it they own their success
they they deserve it but with that comes
a sense of everyone else should pull
themselves up by their bootstraps but
some people don't have boots right and
your boots can be taken away from you
based on pure noise in the system and so
anyway that's my rant about alright that
the inequities are so stark that it ends
up bringing us together towards new
solutions certainly one thing I always
keep in mind is like I'm not working as
hard as the person in the meat
processing plan you know what I mean
like if I win they're like I probably
wouldn't last a week no doubt like and
these are people that are getting paid
minimum wage or close to it and at this
point it's relatively high risk because
you know some of those plants are
getting infected so I agree with you
though that one of the problems with
getting folks at the top engaged in
thinking bigger about what we need to do
is that we've had this kind of savage
meritocracy that if you've climbed up
through it then you've worked really
really hard and so you're like well you
know like I earned it and like you said
they did work really really hard though
you know there are all these structural
things that that often like May
their success possible but they worked
really really hard I like you I admire
entrepreneurs and operators and folks
that kick ass and you know like break
their backs but one of the things I know
is that like that food truck operator
broke his back - or her back and now
their business got blasted to
smithereens through no fault of theirs
like that the thing that breaks my heart
is that like the people who are getting
pummeled the worst right now are the
people who went out on a limb started
something like entrepreneurs a lot of
creatives you know who like went out
there and tried to do something awesome
that they cared about they're getting
destroyed right now possibly for a
generation or more who's making out the
best if you got a good private banking
relationship you know you're like I'm
still trading I mean I saw just now like
the stock market is rebounded to a large
extent like that like the folks who are
the best situated are better insulated
and then if you were out there trying to
do something you cared about you are
probably getting wrecked and like that
that makes me so sad and and it does fly
in the face of what you describe as like
well you know it's like somehow we make
our own luck it's like are you kidding
me like it this thing is just pointing
out how luck dependent we all are yeah
again if you were running the most
successful restaurant in you know any
city on earth right and counted yourself
among the very wealthy as a result you
just happen to be in an industry that
just got zeroed out right the spin of
the roulette wheel here is just
absolutely obvious for people
the distinction you're making with
respect to how people are being helped
here is is that a distinction at the
level of you know whether money is being
effectively targeted to individuals
versus corporations right now yeah yeah
a relatively small fraction of the now
nearly three trillion dollars it's being
dispensed went directly to people most
of it went to big companies which is
getting distributed through banks for
the most part it's one thing that also
shocks and disgust me because there
there's so many people suffering that
are never gonna see a dime of this Sam
and even now there are bills being
considered right now that are gonna send
cash relief to people that somehow the
majority of members of Congress have not
gotten on board with despite the fact
that they've already underwritten like
multiples of that towards big businesses
and so I'm thinking to myself is like if
you can't see the need right now to get
money into people's hands then there's
something seriously wrong with you and
you're still signing off on like giant
corporate bailouts the equivalent
because of these trillions of dollars
trillions of dollars that are getting
produced right now they're being put in
the hands of financial institutions to
distribute in the vast majority of cases
and most of that money is not going to
be seen by the average American that's
that's what's what's happening right now
Sam I mean like then the people think
about the stimulus checks like this
$1,200
you know 500 bucks for kids for millions
of Americans like that was the stimulus
no that's stimulus like that was
something like 250 billion of the like
2.8 Ron it's like maybe 10% of the total
amount went straight to humans and then
the rest of its getting freaking clogged
up in the arteries of these financial
institutions where if you were a nail
salon you're trying to figure out how
the heck to get that money and then like
do you have a relationship with the
right bank
it's literally coming down to that like
you know how many banking relationships
do you think that nail salon or the food
truck has zero probably like maybe one
maybe they have some Citibank business
account that they freakin applied for
you know is that gonna do it like
probably not you know it's like if you
have a random citi bank account like is
that gonna get you the the stimulus
money no it's like what we're talking
about is like
many cases you have like high-level Bay
this is one reason why you saw these
freaking giant companies like roost
Chris and Shake Shack all of a sudden
being like hey we got millions and then
everyone like booing them being like boo
that money's not for you and I hate to
say it but it's like like I don't blame
those companies because it's like well
technically that money was for me
I got it faster than everyone else
because I have a fast track to you know
to like chase his private bank or
whatever it is so this is one reason why
I'm so passionate about the fact that we
need to just change the unit of
distribution like get it to people and
just make it freakin clean transparent
like dollar for dollar instead of just
trusting our systems to do things our
systems are not designed to do and and a
lot of it unfortunately gonna get caught
up in like the the wheels of these
institutions and a fair amount of
corruption in many cases has anyone
worked out the technical requirements of
implementing ubi
do we know how we would build a system
that is you know sufficiently
safeguarded against you know fraud or
anything else that might concern us and
you know where the government can just
hit Send on trillions of dollars in a
circumstance like this yeah so there's a
one proposal that I loved which is that
the Federal Reserve does set up an
account for every single person you know
just you via social security number
here's your Federal Reserve account and
then you can connect to it however you'd
like and they can just put money in it
so I could connect your bank counterfeit
bank account if you don't have a bank
account you can get it in other ways I
mean there are ways you could do it what
I'm what my organization is doing right
now so we I I think I opened up with
like the description of of our trying to
distribute this money so we gave million
dollars to folks in the Bronx through
neighborhood trust but obviously you
know there's so much need everywhere so
we just started taking applications on
our website and then paying people via
venmo or PayPal and we verified who you
are in many cases because we have
hundreds of volunteers who were just
like call you and be like okay here's
what you said about your situation and
who you are is that who you are yes all
right here's the money now we're only
giving two
50 to 500 dollars so we don't care about
you know like fraud like it you could
probably pull one over on humanity for
but we're in a situation where that
should be like the least of our concerns
you know it's like the the house is on
fire you don't care if like you spilled
a drop of water like from the hose the
big problem is that you're like you're
just not actually firing the hose or
like you're not using enough water those
are the real concerns when the economy
is on fire which it is so the government
could do something much more aggressive
than it's doing for people in so many
ways you know it's like like I I don't
hate the use of the IRS and the the tax
refund mechanism to get people money
that's actually a reasonably robust and
time efficient way to go but the lion's
share of the resources of the stimulus
should be going to people not companies
and then we should be exhausting all
these other ways to get people money if
they don't have a tax return if they
don't have a bank account well you know
it's like it pretty much you can imagine
a world where it's like look here's
Federal Reserve or some of these
accounts put money in for you and come
and get it and we'll just verify who you
are and we can have different ways of
doing that and you could even except
frankly a certain level of fraud like
maybe someone managed to like somehow
like you know like there's a social
security number of someone who they
somehow managed to like you know get in
there and the person died and they
didn't tell anyone or whatever the heck
that the source of fraud is but that
should be a very very marginal concern
relative to just getting resources into
people's hands because right now you
have lines around the block for food
banks like people waiting in hours for
food for waiting in lines for hours for
food and this is just beginning
like I understand the way the economy
works where like the there are so many
like 78% of us living paycheck to
paycheck you cut off income for a lot of
them desperation is gonna set in really
really quickly and civilization is not
infinitely resilient it's not like oh
that's gonna suck for you no it's like
no eventually there's going to come out
start taking stuff which is what frankly
like most of us would do if we were put
in desperate enough circumstances that's
what we have to try and head off that to
me is the problem we should be solving
for instead of like oh like how are we
gonna monitor this because like the the
fixation on our institutions and our
bureaucracies that are not set up to do
this very well at all they're gonna miss
millions of people and the suffering is
going to be far and wide and it's going
to spread even to the people that right
now like are not suffering like in this
in the sense of like you're going to and
this to me was one of the underpinnings
like this is enlightened self-interest
it's not like oh I'll be fine you're
screwed it's like if enough people are
screwed then we're all screwed yeah yeah
and frankly that was absolutely obvious
even before the current crisis I mean
just to you when you think of the
conversation around the problem of
homelessness it was becoming more
visible six months ago when you think of
you know the quality of life of a rich
person in a city like San Francisco or
Los Angeles or New York it is speaking
purely out of you know self-interest you
know enlightened or otherwise you know
it is radically diminished by having
homeless people everywhere in sight in
what should be the the nicest cities in
the world who wants to live this way
again forget about the possibility of
actually having compassion for other
human beings and caring about their
well-being even if you're a sociopath
there's no sociopath who wants to have
to step over people on the sidewalk or
just plain out the utter chaos of their
lives whether it's based on mental
illness or drug addiction or just again
just pure bad luck in front of everyone
on a daily basis I mean it's just we
need to figure out how to solve these
these social problems and you can get
there through this you don't even need a
Monica of compassion you just have to be
wisely selfish to see where this is all
headed and why don't want to pull the
brakes I could not agree more
or something basic like having your kids
teacher be able to live within commuting
distance of your school you know might
not even as extreme as like having to
step over homeless people or people who
are hooked on drugs everywhere you go
which is going to be more of an everyday
reality for for more and more people and
this harkens back to the problems the
market wants to solve and doesn't want
to solve if I could come up with AI that
helps drive trucks perfectly that's like
a multi-billion dollar product solution
I'm like one of the wealthiest people in
the country pretty quick but what is my
financial incentive to help the hundreds
of thousands of people who used to drive
those trucks like well nothing really or
if like I revolutionize retail and close
half of America's malls it's like well
I'll be very successful it's like what
is my incentive to somehow look after
the cashiers that no longer have jobs
zero so the the financial incentives
don't involve making that homeless
person stronger and more whole it
doesn't involve improving our mental
health or our soundness and that's what
we have to change like that this is this
is the winner-take-all economy to its
most extreme and history and like you
said even the winners lose you know and
that's not just like you know again like
you said it's not a moral argument it's
not even just like an abstract practical
argument studies have shown that in a
more unequal Society rich people are
less happy yeah then if the society is
more equal so this becomes everyone's
self-interest pretty quickly the
question to me really is whether we can
enact a different set of solutions with
our current political system that truly
is very disconnected very
institutionalized very distrustful of
people overrun by corporate interests
and generally speaking decades behind
the curve like can you catch that up in
the right time frame
that's the mission that was my mission
when I ran that's still my mission even
now
well Andrew it's great to speak with you
and your job just got harder now you're
podcasting yourself now you have an
excuse to blow v8 about all these issues
all the time and I'm looking forward to
that I'm very happy that you and I got
to have a simulcast conversation here
and catch up me too Sam I feel like this
is some kind of crossover special I
don't know if you were a geek growing up
but this is like Marvel and DC getting
together I think both of us are probably
marvel but now super grateful to you for
the friendship and generosity where you
elevated my campaign at a crucial time
it meant the world to me then I'm just
glad that I could live up to your
confidence in me really I remember that
moment when you reached out saying that
you wanted to have me on your podcast
and I felt this I felt like this sense
of like occasion where I felt like this
was going to be the biggest opportunity
I'd have to make my case to people who
cared to people who thought about things
deeply like I knew that instinctively
Sam and when you and I sat down that
those two plus years ago now like it
felt like a bit of history and I can't
tell you how much I appreciate who you
are really like just the fact that you
saw this anonymous guy running for
president on a set of ideas and you
elevated me and those ideas at the
crucial crucial period I'll never forget
you for it I'll always appreciate it how
nice well we'll record a podcast from
the White House one of these days and
when you reboot how old do you Andrew
you're younger than I am 45 in
presidential terms that makes me like a
spring chicken yeah no doubt the story
on your political career is not yet
written so I'm looking forward to it
yeah me too man date at the White House
and yeah it happen all right well good
luck on the podcast in the meantime and
well
again soon of that say I'm stay healthy
thank you Sam
[Music]